I'd like to show you another clip of fox
they had a really fantastic uh guest on
yesterday this guy Dave Rubin he was on
to discuss this and I thought he made a
really good point let's watch you know
she alleges that that her mistakes the
plagiarism accusations were all
corrected but the Harvard honor Council
which is a student group says that
students are not allowed to correct
mistakes without penalties so why should
she be allowed to all of a sudden just
go on after saying well we fixed all
those accusations yeah well let me
answer your previous question very
clearly this is because of the
plagiarism thing not the anti-Semitism
thing these schools and schools that
have allowed Dei to enter and put
everybody in this insane Matrix of
Oppression where again Jews and white
people are sort of at the top of it and
black and brown students are at the
bottom thus they are the oppressed and
can say anything that they want about
the perceived oppressors that's not what
got her fired what got her fired is that
they now have all of these instances of
plagiarism and the Very students who
would be kicked out of school or at
least kicked out of certain programs for
doing just this even this is too blatant
right in their faces so that's really
why she's getting fired here there's
always pressure to Bear but as you noted
the board had already backed her when it
came to that it's only since the
instances of plagiarism have come out
that they finally did the right thing
but again I think it's worth mentioning
you know the question always with these
with these people is okay who's going to
replace them and is there any evidence
that Harvard will suddenly get someone
in charge will be based in meritocracy
and competence and anything else or have
they already gone so down that rabbit
hole of Dei and wokeness that they'll
bring in someone worse that's generally
how they do we got to play more clips of
that guy I mean it's nice when you get
somebody on cable news who knows what
they's doing uh look the point there is
I think the the latter point that I was
trying to make that and this is what
happens with everything right when you
are part of this woke thing uh when you
are a Democrat politician what do I
always say like the only privilege in
America is Democrat privilege you fall
up right you fail up so you destroy San
Francisco if you're Gavin Nome you
become the governor of California like
all of these things you know you're
you're Brian stelter on CNN your show
gets cancelled because you're awful you
become a professor at Harvard you're
Lori Lightfoot mayor of Chicago you
destroy the city of Chicago you become a
professor at Harvard it's interesting
that Harvard seems to be the epicenter
of so much of this so I have no great uh
I have no Grand Illusions here that
suddenly Harvard is going to bring in
somebody who's going to fix all this as
stepanic is pointing out the rot is so
deep the institutional rot there is so
deep over so many decades right they
took over the institutions they have
instituted all of these backwards crazy
racist ideas they have taught children
what to think young people I should say
they've taught young people what to
think instead of how to think and can
any of it be saved I have no idea if any
of could be saved but I do want to
mention one other thing which is that
again I just want to reiterate she is
not being fired because of the
anti-Semitism thing Liz McGill was right
they just they were like all right we'll
take her out Claude Dean gay could have
skated by by being a black woman like it
would have been enough to get her
through the anti-Semitism thing because
of that oppression of uh Olympics that
these people view everything through
it's only because of the plagiarism
thing the the black woman thing that
card would have got her out of
it